alors on va voir si vous vous en
souvenez et on va voir si nos amis
savent qu'ils en sont les auteurs on y
va mon coeur est français montcuq et à
l'international et gym si on les dit
bien très bien au procès c'est une
phrase de jean sont ces gens qui lui
avait écrite pour le 'process' internity
oui trop tard les noms les femmes ont
besoin d'une raison pour faire l'amour
les hommes ont juste besoin d'un endroit
vous d'y arriver à l'aide
narry c'est pas aux diana c'est billy
crystal arménie cristal oui je dans
mafia blues boom alors à huy
alors ça c'est internationales sont à
lire la suite vous en livre être
international fermer les maisons closes
c'est plus qu'un crime c'est un
pléonasme aletti dieu a créé l'alcool
pour que les femmes moches baisse quand
même bien ce jour les chiffres lui ce
coluche elle est bien cette anam ces
jeunes la nuit d'amour avec marilyn
j'aurais préféré qu'on ne le sut ce
point si je puis dire
alors juste points alors ce montant
pourrait virer nous maintenant il s'est
absenté involontaire après je ne suis
pas un nouveau riche je suis un ancien
collège il n'y a pas que l'argent dans
la vie il ya aussi des fourrures et les
bijoux mais west et marlene la belle
femme aussi elizabeth taylor
j'ai compris que le père noël n'existait
pas quand j'avais 5 ans chante dans un
grand magasin il m'a demandé un
autographe
une petite actrice bravo
quand on s'est fait connaître en
choquant on ne peut plus choqué quand
nos shows complets
luc ferry qui est bien le soir des
oscars j'étais entouré de femmes qui
n'arrêtait pas de me demander je peux la
toucher malheureusement elle parlait de
la statuette
c'est ben affleck est bien le travail
d'équipé est essentielle en cas
d'erreurs ça permet d'accuser quelqu'un
d'autre jugnot non un mec que tu adores
tu le cites schéma pourquoi oui à link
est bien faisait beaucoup d'ennemis oui
comme tous les gens qui n'aiment pas les
cons pas mal dit tri dans l'art blier
l'expérience et un peigne que vous donne
la vie quand vous êtes devenu chauve lee
blier encore vous savez ce que c'est la
connerie
imaginez une plage le soleil un whisky
avec des glaçons des nanas autour de
vous vous y êtes
il ya tout le reste c'est de la connerie
j'aime beaucoup la cuisine chinoise mon
plat préféré c'est le numéro 27
ooyala d'imca mais c'est bien pensé qu'
il est bien il ya trois choses dans la
vie que je supporte pas le café brûlant
le champagne qu'elle est femme froide
orson welles jamais été très optimiste à
tel point que j'ai toujours hésité
abonnés pour plus d'un an à magazine six
mois-un dutronc
les mêmes notes de jim carrey qui est
vachement il est bon de jim carrey sait
pas quand on parle à dieu c'est une
prière quand c'est lui qui nous parle de
la schizophrénie tiens justement le côté
positif de la mort c'est qu'on peut
l'être en restant couchés et une pierre
doriz conseil lui fit à la rue qui est
moins des fans de pierre doris les morts
de la chance ils ne voient leur famille
qu'une fois par an à la toussaint j'ai
moi un millionnaire c'est un
milliardaire qui vient de payer ses
impôts
robert lamoureux et la dernière le point
commun entre tous les hommes que j'ai
aimé c'est moi jeanne moreau jeanne
moreau bravo